well the events of 9 11 brought the U.S
together like never before in modern
history was a tragedy that seemed to
unite politicians in both parties as
well as people from every part of the
country in a spirit of patriotism and
togetherness today however exactly 22
years since that fateful day the nation
remains
arguably more divided than ever so what
happened and can be disuniting of the
United States be reverse we'll here to
discuss this is a man who was governor
of New York on September 11th 2001
George Pataki Governor great to have you
on the program especially today thank
you pierce nice being on with you it
must bring back so many evocative
memories for you that awful day
uh awful day is the right word you know
when I go down the ground zero as I
approach it you just have this
tremendous sense of loss you know the
the friends and people you worked with
the firefighters who died that day and
it's and will never will never be able
to bring them back and uh it's just uh
really a sad day in that sense but also
uh you can't help but appreciate the the
courage to how New Yorkers and Americans
responded that day in the weeks and
months thereafter and when I go down
there as well I see the the life the
excitement the vibrancy of lower
Manhattan and that makes me proud that
for all the horror we've come back
stronger than ever in lower Manhattan
that is indisputed to be true I'm in
Manhattan a lot and it's been remarkable
to see how that City but it doesn't
surprise me New York's an incredible
City with Incredible people it has that
Spirit about it reminded me of London
after the Blitz and so on in World War
II but what's happened to the unity that
when America came together after 911 I'd
never seen anything quite like that I
remember George Bush I think we've got a
clip of George W bush the president
throwing the first pitch at the Yankee
Stadium and this was what happened
thank you
so this was the present at the time
George W bush uh being unanimously
cheered by a roaring Yankee Stadium and
Governor when you see that
that couldn't happen anymore things are
so toxic now so tribal so partisan
whoever's president no one's going to
get that kind of response and the latest
poll shows 65 percent of Americans
believe America's never been so divided
do you feel that and if so what is the
answer
appears absolutely I feel that and
that's one of that's the second tragedy
of September 11th one was who we lost
that day but the second is how a country
that was the most unified in my lifetime
is now the most divided I've ever seen
in my lifetime and I I think I don't
mean to be overly simplistic but it
comes down to leadership you need to
have a leader leaders who look to
inspire the people with a common Destiny
going forward and instead for years now
we've had just partisan division aimed
at my party winning more than the other
party and instead of bringing us
together from the top down it's been
about divide for political benefit and I
think that is a tragedy that has hurt
this country but I don't think it's
irreversible you know the spirit of the
American people is still there the
belief in the future of this country is
still there we just need the Right
leader I mean you talk about the Right
leader you know President Biden is not
in America on 9 11. he's in Alaska on
his way back from his foreign travels
I've just seen reports that Ron DeSantis
the governor of Florida is at Ground
Zero that Kamala Harris is there but not
the president of the United States does
that surprise you
um it's disappointing more than
surprising and uh you know I I don't
think President Biden wants to have
anything to do with September 11th you
know uh first of all it resulted in the
Afghanistan War uh and how that ended
under Biden's watch was a catastrophe
that uh we're going to be paying for for
years to come and uh the terrorists came
to America and now we have an open
border and we know that hundreds of
people on the terror watch list have
crossed the southern border and I fear
that because of this absence of
leadership something will happen again
so it's disappointing Biden was there it
doesn't surprise me I think he wants to
distance himself from this as much as
possible but he can't he's the president
of the United States we need him as a
leader a lot of people around the world
are looking at the next American
election and thinking is it really going
to be Biden Trump again is that the best
America can offer at one guy's got
nearly 100 criminal charges that he's
facing the other one barely looks like
he knows what day it is
um do you share that sort of disquiet
that this is the best of the best in
America
absolutely I share that this quiet but
I'm an outlier peers in the sense that I
don't think either one of them is going
to be the nominee I think uh the
Democratic Leadership that helped Biden
basically put Biden in in 2020 because
they knew Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren and Kamala Harris were all losers
and they've got rally behind Biden
I'm sorry quickly we've run out of time
I'd love to get you back because I'm
really enjoying this conversation please
come back another time it's been great
having you on sense and I appreciate it